[Applause]
it was important for china to excel at
the tokyo games
because they coincided with another
cause for celebration
the 100th anniversary of china's
communist party
having to see its athletes to excel in
these games
will validate the ccp's leadership as it
shows
china has the capability to win and to
excel
in the olympics and that will boost the
national confidence
and strengthen unity for china's leaders
olympic gold medals
represent an important projection of
power which is why
so much money is invested in finding the
very best
in china there's so many people that the
goal is to to weed through the many
people that are going through the system
and find the one that they think will
best represent the country
and is that more win at all costs than
another model is hard to say but
but they're there to win they're not
they're not there to come second that's
for sure
on the eve of the tokyo games the head
of china's olympic committee
said he wanted his country to win as
many gold medals as possible
that added to the pressure on china's
athletes and that same pressure
will doubtless be there when china hosts
the winter games
in just six months some of that pressure
was evident
when china's table tennis team lost to
japan
we lost the gold medal in the mixed
doubles match but our two teammates
lou shawn and xi singh tried their best
winning silver was not good enough
though and the duo
were attacked on chinese social media
with some bloggers
accusing them of failing the nation the
human story of somebody trying to do
their best to win a match gets caught up
in
historical or political events that have
nothing to do with the athletes
like japan china is tackling a
resurgence
in covid 19 along with its variants
winter games organizers also face other
challenges
corporate boycotts and protests
presumably there would be athletes
protest
uh against the china's human rights
issues
in relating to sensitive topics to china
like tibet xinjiang hong kong
etc and also others may politicize
public health issues during the protest
it's exactly 13 years since beijing
hosted the summer games
a moment seen as a high point in chinese
soft power
china's leader xi jinping will want to
ensure
that same euphoria can be repeated in
six months
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong